From the snowy peaks of the Himalayas,...
...peaceful Buddhist temples and lush green nature parks,...
...Nepal really has something for everyone.
Backpackers can spend as little as 20 to 30 dollars a day...
...in total for a bed for the night,...
...transport, attraction prices and food.
What's even better is that this trekkers' paradise is friendly on a shoestring budget,...
...even massive trekking trips...
...such as an 11-day hike in Langtang Valley will only set you back a few hundred dollars,...
...a quarter of what a trek to Everest base camp would cost.
If you're feeling hungry, dal bhat, or lentils with rice, is a local favorite...
...and it will cost you less than one dollar.